amazing how if you remember this when
this was going on a year and a half ago
when I was upset that they didn't let
Bernie win because when I said so do you
remember the day where it all it kind of
all happened like within 24 48 Hours
where all of a sudden oh okay this guy's
ahead no this person's ahead no Amy this
no Elizabeth Warren this no Pete this no
uh Bernie Sanders says no everyone's
dropping out and they're getting behind
job and they're like wait what I can
tell you exactly how that happened yeah
I mean I remember but go ahead yeah so
Bernie won the first three states now
look mainstream media is not in the they
don't they're not in the business of
manufacturing news they're in the
business of manufacturing consent okay
so Noam Chomps he wrote about this
decades ago and he's absolutely right so
they do propaganda for a living it's the
marketing armor of corporate rule so
when Bernie won the first three states
they did not do what they always do when
an establishment candidate either a
Republican or Democrat wins the first
three states everybody in media goes oh
my God we have the presumptive winner
everybody clear the field clearly Iowa
New Hampshire it's over right they do
that even when Hillary Clinton loses one
of them even before there was any
election they were like Hillary
Clinton's obviously the winner Hillary
Clinton leading in fact I criticized CNN
on CNN for doing this they used to count
her delegates which were the
establishment Democratic politicians
before a single vote was in so they're
like Hillary Clinton has a 500 to
nothing lead on Bernie Sanders why is
Bernie Sanders still in the race right
so Bernie wins the first three they're
like oh yeah whatever okay no big deal I
mean it's he's not necessarily going to
win he's I mean he's unelectable he's
unelectable but they panicked internally
they panicked and then you saw chucked
out and others come out and go oh
Bernie's brown shirts and and by the way
these are this is on msnbc's so-called
liberal channel right uh and then Chris
Matthews came on and said oh you know
people like Bernie wins uh people are
going to get shot in Central Park uh and
and I remember when Castro was
threatening to do that Etc and they go
they they all pylon and the worst of the
worst was MSNBC there are wolf in
sheep's clothing so they come in oh
we're liberal we're on the left oh my
God but Bernie's unelectable no
Progressive was electable oh we brought
in Claire mccaskill to be our expert
wait didn't she get her ass handed to
her even though she was an incumbent she
ran all the way right wing try to copy
the Republicans it's a losing strategy
every single time but MSNBC loves it
because it's economically conservative
and by the way I have personal
experience at MSNBC I I partly got moved
out of prime time because I was
criticizing Barack Obama and they hated
that and they literally told me so
there's no question that they're
economically right away so so then so
then for me this is how I see it I see
Bernie and Trump as the same people uh
and I know you may not agree with this
or you may not like this but I see them
as same people let me explain to you why
because I think uh the left like I'm
surprised the right didn't do to Trump
what the left it to burning I'm very
surprised they didn't they tried every
single way to get this guy to not be a
candidate because they don't have
control over the guy the people they
fear is whoever they don't control you
can't control Bernie you can't control
Trump that's why I think they're the
same I don't sit there and I agree with
Bernie's policies I'm not a socialist I
escaped around to not have to deal with
the high taxes and to control all that
that's the fear that a lot of immigrants
that leave their own countries who come
here and I know you're one as well but
that's what a lot of people from you
know that and that's capitalists they
don't want to deal with that so on the
other side with Trump he was a loose
cannon he's getting out there calling
out they're pretty much calling out the
same people Trump and Bernie are calling
out the establishment they're both
calling out some of the same swamps same
people even though Bernie's a lot more
part of the swamp you know a lot of
people on the right will say he's never
had a real job all this other stuff and
a lot of people on the left will say
Trump's never been involved in politics
what the hell does he know about getting
policies and all this other stuff you'll
hear some of those things but that's why
I think those two were the same but even
going back to it so if you say well yeah
you know it's CNN and you know all these
guys they're still fiscally on the right
you know DeSantis has got tens of
millions of eyeballs right now people
have to follow the guy and he may be
their next Superstar you know even on
Trump you got 78 million eyeballs
whatever the number is that he got the
votes picker 81 said 8178 I don't I
don't know if I'm getting the numbers
right or not but so he's got 78 million
eyeballs if you're not going to give
that guy any credit and so this will go
to my next question with you and I'm
really curious on what you're going to
say with this so
everybody I think a lot of times and
maybe this is a left and the right thing
but for the last six years it was more
of a left thing left a media side they
did not know if Russia was real but man
they kept talking about it like a broken
record they had no clue if this thing
was real but thank God they had some
story to talk about every day viewership
another thing with Russia another you
know who's the one guy that got up shift
what shifts first Adam Schiff
oh my God he's saying it there's got to
be something it's like what are you
talking about and the next thing you
know you find out that uh with the
report that came out that uh what's the
report that came out with not the
Mueller the other one that just the
spying on the Durham Durham report that
comes out hey this is really what was
going on well we don't really know this
and then they stopped talking about it
and then you see the hunter Brighton
laptop you know spits everybody's like
no this is just medium misinformation
another Republican misinformation
another Russian misinformation campaign
and then folks are sitting there and I'm
looking at CNN's eyeballs so folks are
sitting there saying who the hell do you
believe to today do you believe them do
you believe who do you believe today
it's a very hard for the regular viewer
and The Listener that's not involved in
the politics like you are that they've
committed their life to that this is
their work it's the average guy that's
like listen I'm just trying to see who I
believe you know you you seem you know
inconsistent you seem consistent you
seem consistent you seem inconsistent
who the hell do I believe that's why I
say I think uh I think CNN MSNBC a lot
of the mainstream media lost a lot of
people because all they want to defend
is
maybe not progressives but Democrats on
the left and they don't want to support
anything that the Republicans are
talking about and they lost a lot of
people so I gotta flip your frame here
because you're you're right on so many
things but it's just the wording is
often and it makes a big thing you speak
English it's not my first time give me a
break it's my fifth Language by the way
not my first language either
um so here's what I mean by that it
seems like they're supporting Democrats
but they're not like
I gave you the example of Chris Christie
I gave the example of John McCain I can
give you tons of flowers yeah tons of
corporate Republicans that the
establishment press supports as well now
they're but yes they're mainly in love
with corporate Democrats that is true
okay because corporate Democrats
unfortunately it's it pains me and
that's why I fight them so much have
become the most corporate right uh we
will do whatever corporations say and
we'll pretend that there's change on the
outside oh my God we've got a black
person who's doing everything
corporations want so everything is fixed
no everything is not fixed so for
example 15 minimum wage is so important
to the black community
47 of blacks in this country make less
than 15 an hour right what what do debt
corporate Democrats do they put out
somebody like Hakeem Jeffries to say now
he goes oh I'm for the 15 minimum wage
but behind the scenes he helps to kill
the 15 minimum wage but as long as we
got the right face on it corporate rule
is awesome no it is not awesome so it's
not that they're pro-democrat it's that
they're pro-corporate Rule and and and
so the populism that you're seeing the
similarity between Trump and Bernie
you're right you're not right it's not
they don't they're not similar on
policies of course not right and they're
not and they're not similar on on
earnestness like Bernie's super Earnest
I think Trump is a grade A con man right
but they're both cannot be controlled
that is true and that is why
establishment media despises them and so
establishment media has lied to us our
entire lives can I can you draw a
correlation to what you're saying
because the control neither of you two
can be controlled and I think that's
something that you both can agree upon
is that you'd like to be able to say
what the hell ever you want to say do
what you want to do in America exactly I
mean that that's undeniable uh who wants
to be controlled but you made a couple
points here and I just want to kind of
put the align the stars and see if I'm
right here essentially what you're
talking about is Old School versus new
school now you brought up the we started
off the conversation with media and the
establishment media Legacy Media versus
New Media and the democratization of
media then you moved on to establishment
politics versus basically the trumps and
the Bernies and the aocs or you know
messing up the establishment and I'll
even go one further that's essentially
what crypto is doing to you know uh
typical mainstream you know the monetary
system essentially what is happening is
here is the establishment wants to
control what they estab what they
control you know and and what you're
basically saying and what whether you're
a Bernie guy or a trump guy is they're
rattling a lot of cages and the
establishment don't like that too much
yeah 100 and Patrick let me just go back
to agreeing with you on the core premise
which is really important right so the
reason why people are looking through
these Alternatives now the trumps the
Bernies everything else and our
programming all the different right-wing
left-wing Etc is because the one thing
we all know for sure and I'll give the
right wing credit on this they know this
better than the left wing does okay uh
is that the politicians are full of [ __ ]
okay and and what do what has
establishment media told us our whole
lives the politicians are honest they're
having real debates they're all really
principled and they're honorable and you
have to respect them and there were
worthy of so much respect whereas we
look at them and go well that's that guy
is obviously lying that guy's obviously
cheesy that guy's the most plastic
person I have ever met that's why in
2016 everybody in the Press said it's
going to be Jeb Bush or Marco Rubio and
I said you guys are a joke there's no
chance it's going to be that Marco Rubio
is a boy okay he's the most plastic fake
politician you'll ever meet in your
entire life and that's why corporate
media loved them they loved him they're
like it's going to be Rubio it's got to
be Ruby I'm like have you guys looked at
a single goddamn poll I said Trump would
win the Republican primary about four
months before they started voting you
know why I'm not a genius one I just
know the country's in a populist mood
they hate the lies of the establishment
media about how politicians are so
goddamn wonderful because that's just
the most obvious lie of all time right
and secondly I could read a poll and
every poll had trumpet number one by a
lot and they're like no don't believe
you're Lying Eyes by the way every poll
in 2016 had Bernie beating Trump and by
a large Origins and Hillary Clinton was
losing to Trump and every day ABC CBS
NBC all of them would come out and lie
to the American people and say Hillary
Clinton could beat Trump Hillary Clinton
is better at beating Trump than Bernie
Hillary Clinton is more electable every
one of them was alive you think Bernie
could have beaten Trump it's not me it's
the American people the polling
indicated he clearly could have beaten
Trump on Election Day now I know they
didn't run an election against each
other right on Election Day Bernie was
beating Trump by 12 points so you run an
election the Republican spear him you're
going to wear down that 12 right
but you're not going to wear down the
whole 12-12 is a giant monster League do
you remember those pulls back that it's
saying that polls are credible but I
mean that's a whole nother first of all
first of all what we learned about polls
in 2015 2016 none of them were right so
the The credibility of the only poll I
may give some Credence to is I I look at
Pew was good Gallup is relatively
trusting any Fox News Post CNN Paul
MSNBC I don't I don't look at any of
that stuff those are the only two I pay
attention to if you enjoyed this short
clip click over here to watch another
short clip and if you want to watch the
entire episode the entire podcast click
here
[Music]